[Music]
welcoming for a fireside chat
christopher bishop and harry shum great
harry first of all thanks hugely for
taking the time to join us I know you've
had an incredibly busy day in just I
guess you've literally just flown back
into Seattle so tell us what you know
today yeah well first of all
congratulations Chris in a boasts for
the incredible lab you have used over 20
years in Cambridge and of course you
know is nothing beats this guidon of the
Royal Society is dining on the same book
as Newton its incredible achievement I
just came back about the two hours ago
I was this morning at this big Microsoft
internal events we called it ready this
is actually week-long event for our
sales force half of our company roughly
half of our company is actually working
on the sales and marketing side every
year we use this opportunity to share
with our fields the sales force what's
happening in the company and we also
live broadcast the all those
presentations from the conference and
across the company it happens to be in
Vegas it's only 114 degrees there it's
just incredible I hardly went outside
and so I was so happy to come back to
join you and the faculty summit that's
great yeah so I thought we did have
maybe 20 minutes or so you and I having
a bit of a chat about AI and and then
after that we'll open it up to the
audience so please you know be thinking
of some interesting questions on the
topic of AI for Harry but maybe I can
just dive right in and I'm going to
start with a fairly tough question
because this is a bit like asking
parents about their favorite child or
something so I mean there's a lot of
work in NSR worldwide around
but other anything's that particularly
stand out right that's really a tough
one and I guess if I can take this one
the rest it would be easy it's just so
many exciting things going on MSR and I
feel extremely fortunate and very proud
what we have done in the last 26 years
EMS are they they are actually three
areas I recently very excited about it
and they're not surprisingly you would
agree that AI is certainly one of them I
get to that later too are the areas I
feel very very excited about you know
one is actually very forward-looking the
other one is also very very timely the
one very forward-looking is quantum
computing we have been working on the
station cue quantum computing for a long
long time I think we're getting to a
point that's in the way we feel we are
getting very close together stable you
know qubits that we can produce
certainly you know Mike Friedman and
will be able to tell you a lot more
details I want there come can share with
you is that you know a few so confidence
that we actually started to really work
with the experimental physicists to
really get to the physics level how can
we really construct those qubits once
you get enough of those creepies and the
great things can happen the other area I
feel very very excited about and they're
very timely for my Microsoft is on
security and the privacy specifically on
security are this incredible initiative
in across all our lives certainly you
know in Cambridge lab as well as on this
what we call the confidential computing
and the secure computing the idea there
is that really you know not only can do
encryption you know addressed and on the
go but also during computation so this
has been a very exciting research area
for us over quite a few years it's
fantastic to see we have an opportunity
to move those technology into Microsoft
products certainly I want to be relevant
for
of course absolutely driven and we care
about the exactly machine securities
yeah it has profoundly impacts and there
are over many many things that we want
to do at Microsoft and the AI of course
there are many things that we do I heard
Eric give a fantastic presentation this
morning and I had the opportunity goes
through his slides earlier I would do
many things and I'm not going to talk
about a lot of things in the Erica
mentioned about I just just bring a
couple of examples that where I see
great MS our research have incredible
impact on the products you know one of
those areas is actually machine reading
a lot of interesting things happening in
natural language and we as a company
deal with a lot of text whether it's
email web page or even any kind of
documents there's so much that we can do
we abstract absolutely working hard on
that office office 365 outlook in the
world and many of those things we depend
on a lot of MSR technology along this
line we loosely call the machine machine
reading comprehension the other areas
actually are probably a little bit of
personal buyers is really that the
connection between the visual images
videos and natural language description
sometimes people called the captions
captions from image and captions from
video I think it shoe you know image
understanding has to be connected with
natural language actually our this
Sunday this Sunday it's a little bit
embarrassing I was invited to go give
keynote at the cvpr
which used to be my main conference
until 2007 I believe 2007 was the last
time I really participated at the cvpr
this time I got an a chance to go attend
again and they gave a keynote you know
mostly really about sharing some lessons
we have learned from Microsoft the title
of my talk is called commercializing
computer vision so I will talk about a
few examples including hololens how we
actually
organize research efforts how we
actually do move the research from to
the product side and there is a flywheel
that's great actually that's a good a
good hook into my next question which is
sort of step back a little bit and a few
months ago the company created this new
organization a I&R and appointed you as
the leader of this so can you tell us a
little bit about a inr and its mission
yeah well I am incredibly excited about
and they're very honored to have this
opportunity to lead a R&R for Microsoft
a INR is actually our force engineering
division and research division and
honors research hours research ei I and
the research the other three parts of
engineering groups in case you don't
know and the curious now those three are
Windows and devices office productivity
and clouds and enterprise AI and the
research is the first one and the latest
and the smallest one actually we only
have 7500 people in our division so but
it's very timely and important for the
company as you see you know that the
incredible progress has been made in the
last several years in particular in AI
many areas of AI many of those great
examples this morning from Eric you
already seen but we we feel this is
really the right time to not only degree
the research but also really having
impact on Microsoft Business first of
all through products and the services
and the opportunities to really
democratize AI technology to third
parties to our customers so that is that
the really stunning point and the
recently I had the option have had a lot
of opportunities talking to many people
outside of Microsoft as well including
many CEOs CEOs and the engineering
leaders everyone is just the so excited
about AI and also so worried that you
know what if we miss this day I think I
think it is certainly a lot of hype over
there my joke is that you know you have
to claim that you like and you do AI
artificial intelligence because the
opposite of artificial intelligence is
natural stupidity so you just have to
say it you know if you don't do AI what
else did you do so that's a problem and
but the seriously or serious notes are
we really believe they are great
opportunities for the company and for
our customers even more importantly and
anything particularly particular
products or services that you see coming
along yeah I'd be happy to share more in
the so the way we think about with the
AI and the research division is really
about you know what kind of really
products and services that we can offer
so buying a large you we think about in
those three lines of products that we
build the first one is really the first
party AI products that you probably feel
reasonable a long line of say you know
search engine being and the digital
assistance like a katana I certainly
very much believe in that the ultimate
form of AI is actually in digital
assistance in the right place right time
with right information helping you do
the right things still very very early
along that line we actually do very good
work on chatbots so we have been
building chair parts like no one else
especially we start from China great
success with showers then we doing Reena
in Japan so in United States and within
rule in India so continue to expand our
effort so this is one line of products
that we feel very committed and the
long-term we'll keep pushing the second
line of products are also very
reasonable for Microsoft takeout is what
we call infusing AI into every single
product and the service microsoft offers
especially with office imagine you know
that with powerpoints you know we
already embedded in a machine
translation to powerpoints and when you
do PowerPoint presentation the audience
depending on the
what kind of languages they like they
can actually tune into that language
another thing we actually incorporated
into PowerPoint is actually our image
caption so now when you import an image
into powerpoints you know immediately we
can offer you image caption see if we
feel confident if we're not confident
after analyzing the picture we might be
confident enough to show you some
entities detected from the image so it's
still very early but with PowerPoint we
actually every day we actually have 10
million images actually get captioned
and we also have in a Word PowerPoint
and many other things that we can do the
critic from your lab for example you
know with Excel you know what we are
doing with as you import data into
various cells you know what kind of
things you can process they're using
some machine learning and AI tech so
that's really second line of work that
we do and I should also mention about
really applying AI you know into our
cloud as Yui is becoming the most
intelligent cloud literally you know and
if we look at what kind of AI
capabilities we can offer there the
third line of our products are that is I
would say is pretty new and is something
that I have thought of law in the heart
and have decided that we'll have to take
that off it's really the new and the
emerging business processes as we think
about you know all different kind of
verticals and all different vertical
industries and all different kind of
horizontal business processes I
certainly believe that they will all be
disrupted by AI and the data the
vertical industries like health
healthcare you know something you Peter
and Chris Jones and they've been working
on they're just so obvious that we
should get in you know apply our AI
technology you know the challenges that
you know what we and with what business
model and how should we think about the
partnership and as we think about the
horizontals you know it may be it's even
more interesting in all the business
processes so we actually our deal with
today like sales in the marketing like a
custom support and a custom sir
like a China recruiting all those things
are will be transformed it's just so
obvious so obvious you're being
everyone's mind now you actually have a
data now we actually can do the process
now you can apply a I so those things in
my minds will be low-hanging fruits and
also to speak if you care about creating
a new business
so those three directions are what we
now focus on in Microsoft especially for
AI and R but it's really not just us you
know we we work together with other
parts of the company that's pretty
amazing time to be in the field
absolutely absolutely yeah let me ask
you a little bit about Microsoft in
particular how would you say that
Microsoft's approach to AI perhaps a
differs from those of others what makes
Microsoft special when it comes to their
well Chris I would start by asking a
slightly more general question that they
know what is know especially about
Microsoft I think every company has its
own culture has its own mission has its
own point of view you know why should we
even because this no Satya you know very
clear that we should always question
ourselves what would people miss if we
simply just disappeared as a company I
think we are very very clear that we
exist to serve other people and other
companies our company mission statement
is incredibly you know Chris in my
opinion that's in power every person and
every organization on the planet to
achieve more now is a I so that is
really the high-level guiding principle
so so do that with AI and the more
specifically I would say if we look at
you know our position our SS you know
our history I think we approach AI in a
both you know that was a very practical
approach yet with long term commitment I
started with long term commitment so we
started Microsoft Research 26 years ago
at that time you know Bill Gates said
Wow wouldn't that be nice you know
someday computers could see here talk
and understand
human beings you know what is that no
those computers are called a is so most
people don't know that among the first
group so we ever started in the Redman
lab that's the first lab we ever started
the first of three groups or natural
language group speech group and the
computer vision group so we started that
you know 20 60 years ago
you know anticipating you know AI we
make a greedy progress in a January I
and walk towards the NRA I we definitely
continue to have this commitment and the
confidence will continue investing in
research really take out those very
tough problems you know the question
that you always want to address in the
Eric sue and many others you know care
about it will continue to push that yet
at the same time I would say would you
have those products that can infuse a I
to immediately help our customers I
already mentioned about in a PowerPoint
I already mentioned about you know the
cloud you can also Excel you can imagine
that in a word will become more
intelligence in the word should become
really writing to much more intelligence
than today even more interesting to me
you know my favorite the application our
day of AI is actually Outlook there's
really no reason why outlook search is
so difficult and the smarter reply is
not very smart and the reminders are not
very intelligence all those things now
we a IR work together with office teams
in a very very closely so so I would say
that you know first of all we have our
own company's mission you know that
really guides our AI work and then we
are both practical and the long-term
that sounds great so so a lot of
opportunities then for AI what about
what about the other side what about the
risks associated I mean do you do you
wake up at three am worried about killer
robots and lasers any rest in iiiiii do
you fire don't worry about those
products yeah they are there are many
things we shoot in a worried about in
there
but I'm not too worried about in things
like super intelligence and but they are
practical things we do need to worry
about in my opinion the first thing I
would say probably is you know whatever
AI applied to the physical world
concrete example is actually
self-driving cars I would predict that
the most challenging time would be when
half of those cars on the street are
self-driving and half of them is still
human driving I don't think we really
understand enough yet I think I think
we're fooling ourselves just saying no
today no autonomous driving is already
there I it's just going to take some
time I I
I learned something just a couple of
weeks ago at that MIT advisory board
meeting
Ronnie Brooks was there talking about
the robotics and inevitably one of the
topics there was actually self-driving
and he if I understand in his point of
view he's actually very cautious about
how soon we always see autonomous
driving cars there his kind of argument
is straightforward he said look if you
drive in Cambridge Boston is that the
fake Cambridge you know the real one so
if we drive in Cambridge you really
couldn't drive if you don't violate the
traffic laws
well now how did you how did you program
into that and I think that is something
that you know we're still learning you
see very very early and the direction is
very clear is just about the staging the
other thing you know we we as a company
as in the industry are worried about is
that the perf on the impact with AI with
automation that we will see on the job
market
I think you know every technology
disruption every test that technology
innovating we have certain impacts but
this time I think people tend to believe
this thing is probably going to be more
real than than others
we don't understand that you know what
kind of new jobs you know it will open
up we already see some jobs you know
will be transformed so so those are the
things that actually we worry about as a
company and maybe the last thing I
personally in a worried about say I not
much about sippy-sip
intelligence it's really that you know
the reason AI is so so different from
many other incredible you know
innovations in the history of human
being is that most of the previous
innovations there is much about
extending human physical capability and
this time with AI we're talking about
the extending bring powers as well yet
we don't really understand the human
brains and the neuroscience is still in
my opinion still very much in an early
stage so something that you know we keep
learning I think also there's a sort of
a risk the other way there's the rest of
things that may not go as well as we
hope but I I wonder also that with you
know very justifiable concerns about
about the danger about privacy security
and so on that we might some go to from
the other direction and then actually I
mean in particular in the healthcare
space for instance there's tremendous
societal benefit that we can see is is
potential is latent there in AI and
that's right we may shut that out if we
if we over react to some injury so it
feels like we need to find the right so
middle-ground right I think the one
small step toward that first of all I
totally agree with you on that
a very small step step in the towards
that you know we have been learning you
know through the development of many you
know AI products especially through our
chat box is really this whole AI thing
is not just about you know q IQ
intelligence you know it has a lot
what's it's all about that is about
smart it's actually more about empathy
and understanding you know just like
humans like an EQ so it's something that
you know we still learn you know what
does this even mean and when you
interact with a human being and uh you
know when did you make this kind of
recommendation when did you interrupt in
a lot of the things I think is still
very very early no my favorite example
the example is actually I was talking to
you the showers team in Beijing and the
the chat pod knows where this person is
in a roughly stripy and others and it's
let's just say that it's already you
know 1 1 a.m. in the morning and this
person keeps talking to the chat bot
so shoot chat bot slows down the
response should chat bot say oh you
should go back to you to sleep now what
if it's already 2 a.m. what if it's
actually 3 a.m. you know does chat bot
there's a chat but have any
responsibility so those things we just
which is just very very early you know
it's also we just have to really learn
you know along the way you know how to
design this kind of AI products yeah
it's really interesting and and of
course I needs input from lots of
different disciplines right not from you
know IT technologists yet you know
social scientists and riot many many
others I'm conscious at the time I'm
keen to open this up to questions but
there's just one more question I just I
think I'd like to touch on because I
know this is a tremendous interest not
just to Microsoft of the whole IT
industry but to industry generally and
of course the academic world which is
this extraordinary explosion we've seen
in demand for talent in this space
and what are your thoughts on the talent
pipeline and what we could do well it's
truly amazing to see you know how
excited people are about AI you know
first of all then you know how hungry
you know the companies are hiring AI
talent you know we all know that you
know just the price tag is just in the
sky sky high not too long ago I was at
at the forum I said to the press I said
looking on nowaday if a young kid knows
how to train five layers of neural net
you know the kid can absolutely demand
six figures if the kid can train you
know 50 layers of neural net the kid
probably wants in the seven figures so
it's just that is that the talent mark
is very very hard out there I think this
is the where we should work together
with the academia to train the next
generation of AI talent you know it's
you know students really know you know
what to do what kind of tools they can
do at the same time Microsoft companies
like Microsoft you know have
responsibilities to come up with the
right tools in Microsoft we certainly do
we actually do the two kinds of tools
you know one is actually for developers
the other one is actually for data
scientists in Diwali the scientists we
have Azure machine learning go all the
way into and how we train those models
and attune those models for developers
we have in a cognitive service API sand
we should do even better you know coming
up with visual studio type of tools and
so that you know we can actually help
you put together project and the debug
the whole process and then compile that
and take all kind of you know framework
to compile together all the way to
different the kind of running platforms
like you know as you as your waste GPU
or even your home machine or even to
Raspberry Pi so those things I think we
have responsibility maybe last thing I
can share with the audience is that in
the we as a company of course struggle
to train our own AI talents so much so I
decided to start an AI school several
months ago it turns out to be a huge
yes I know everyone wants to learn AI
and of course we want to train every
engineer developer to become an AI
engineer would love to learn from you
the best of practices and they even
partner together yep great thanks very
is fantastic so let's open it up to
questions we have various roving mics so
just put your hand up somebody will give
you a microphone and have somebody here
so yep number three hi my University of
Illinois I was just wondering whether
you could expand a little bit more on
what you see the role of academia to be
and what we can do is earn yes faculty
well that that's something that's a big
question the way we look at that is
Microsoft Research has had a in a very
rich history of collaborating with many
universities and many university
professors I feel you know very honoured
that you know many of you are choose to
come to visit us at this time and coming
to you faculty summit you have a chance
that we can exchange ideas then we
figure out things even more things that
we can work together for Microsoft and
especially for Microsoft Research you
know we're very open you know we we do a
lot of a lot of projects and we write a
lot of papers many of those papers we
jointly do with the professors and the
students I I don't really have anything
that is specifically said you know in
general you know how professors should
work with us or work with others I think
everyone has a different situation I I
don't know Chris you want to Adams and I
know you do you do things very
successfully like work with some
universities in Europe like a recent
announcement with the answer that there
might be a great example you can share
that sure so I think this collaboration
with the academic world is a very deep
one and incredibly important and I like
to think that it's mutually beneficial
as Harry mentioned just last week we
announced another collaboration this is
with max Welling University of
stirred an and are really sort of two
threads to this one is around this
talent pipeline so really trying to
partner with academia because I think
it's in everybody's interest that we
really have a strong talent pipeline of
the next generation of AI researchers
coming along so one of the things we do
with Amsterdam but actually more
generally across Europe because we we
fund actually a very large number of PhD
students but we don't just fund the
students I think more importantly we
actually almost all of those students
are Co supervised by researchers in MSR
and so it's a way of sort of adding some
intellectual horsepower that that
augments that available in the
universities and also helps the students
get a little bit of a more of an
industrial perspective as well to
complement the academic perspective and
then so that's one strand and then the
other strand is on the research side
where we're looking at some of the the
really cutting-edge the futuristic the
very long-term aspects of things are on
machine learning and AI where we we see
really complementary strengths so in
case the University of Amsterdam real
tremendous strength in areas around
unsupervised learning and rich probably
stick models combining probe listing
methods with deep learning looking at
things like causal discovery from data
and and show we have expertise in MSR in
those areas but but you know this is a
vast and very active field and we can't
do everything on our own and so these
partnerships are incredibly beneficial
so I think those two things both the the
talent pipeline and also the the
research collaboration just incredibly
important to us who's next
okay yes number two if you just give us
your name and affiliation as well that'd
be fantastic Thanks
hi I am Barbara gross from Harvard so
you can tell by my gray hair that in a
few decades
I'm gonna retire and the advice for
people retiring is to diversify their
portfolio so I see that you're making a
really heavy investment in deep learning
you can also tell from my gray hair that
I've been an AI for even more decades an
MSR has existed and I've seen these
trends where there's one technique
that's everything and deep learning is
done great things but I'm wondering how
diversified you see your portfolio of a
in terms of the research and in terms of
your school listen to my talk tomorrow
that's part of the answer yeah yeah so I
so you know deep learning has been a
undoubtedly a breakthrough so there are
things that we now do much with much
higher levels of performance than we did
before I think probably that
breakthrough and deep learning has
really rejuvenated the whole field in
some sense the reason we're excited
about AI is because of that however the
idea that everything can be solved by
just shoveling label data through a deep
neural network of course be completely
naive I mean it's so I think it's in is
inject a lot of energy and enthusiasm
into the field which is fantastic
I also think that it offers a new
building block that we can combine with
other techniques and that can amplify
those other techniques and can advance
the whole field but it's certainly not
on its own a complete solution to all
the things we want to achieve so so yes
I'm giving a talk tomorrow a keynote
which which I'll talk about some
somewhat broader perspective on machine
learning that hopefully will help answer
the question I add a little bit well
first of all Barbara welcome to
Microsoft again and we love you you
should come to visit us more often
Erica always talks about the Union and
the send more students to us and I I
really think that you know we first of
all should thank deep learning you know
for its incredible contribution and the
impact in the field of AI and a lot of
excitement seen because of the deep
learning in certain areas it actually
worked beautifully in this speech
recognition vision recognition and and
other things like deep reinforcement
learning I don't think people are naive
that you know thinking just the deep
learning is going to solve every problem
and I don't think people feel that way
but until we actually can build the
tools that incorporate a lot of
interesting deep learning models to a
way that's you know millions and
millions of developers engineers can
easily do that it's just like solving
second order in the differential
equation or whatever I I think the
computing and the people will still be
mystified
it's you know what this deep learning
really is and what's what's what's
really going on I hope that in a way you
know next few years you know we'll be
able to contribute in a waste greedy
tools coming from Microsoft if you
really look at what's happening in deep
learning a lot of those efforts has been
really on the kind of architecture
design of the deep neural nets that
actually can perform better than others
and then you think about you know really
deep intellectual contributions coming
out of the field they do have something
like you know generative as adversarial
networks soon as a few things like that
I'd love to see even more I think we
maybe we should do motive learning
research and we've seen if we see more
coming out of that but still you have to
go back to those fundamentals many of
those things know Eric talked about we
certainly diversify in MS Rai in the
areas that we focus on get you the deep
understanding of what is the
intelligence in the what is cognition
you know how did you really build the
models so that's what we do here great
fantastic is next in the back right at
leave in the far corner of the back is
somebody okay
number three hi David cargo MIT so
what's been striking me today in a lot
of presentations is how a lot of the
work that's going on in AI is about
getting computers to do things that like
reading or having a conversation that
even relatively untrained humans are
actually quite good at and I wonder if
you could talk a little bit about I mean
we we know that the downsides of that
for for the future of work and things
like that but I wonder if you can talk a
little about ways that AI might
complement humans and empower them to do
things that they can't do as opposed to
replacing things that they're already
pretty good at
maybe I started that Chris you can add
more and I saw that I'm thank you very
much David did not I hate to use this
marketing slogan but that sabaki new
slogan we use that the Microsoft when we
talk about talk about Microsoft where we
say Microsoft AI is all about amplifying
human ingenuity it's really about you
know adding more value to humans we talk
about it's all about the reason we
actually do Microsoft ai is about the
men and machine partnership something
that Chris Eric and others from MSR have
helped you know our CEO our senior
leadership team to really frame you know
what we really do there I think there
are numerous examples where that AI asks
value there I give you a very trivial
example that you know I just showed this
morning and at our internal event this
morning at the Vegas is actually this
intelligent camera app so something we
actually released about a year ago it's
called Microsoft pix it's an int it's an
intelligent camera apps it has a lot of
a lot of interesting technologies that
in fact we use the 20 some papers in the
coming from MSR and put all those text
there but I'll give you one example that
is actually now if you use this app you
take a picture of anyone I guarantee you
your eyes will be open so is this a
reasonable example either so how did you
guarantee when you take a picture of
someone in the you know this person's
eye eyes are always open so and it turns
out that you know we are have already
have had a know this this kind of
computer vision machine learning
techniques there the way you do that is
you really you know taken a longer
sequence you know typically we take 10
frames and the chances are you are not
going to blink that long
a human can if you take ten pictures
then a human can go through it and find
one with the eyes open
I think it's debatable I think Christie
should add something you have been
thinking about in a man-machine
partnership you know how we think about
this in Microsoft sure I think first of
all this idea of artificial intelligence
being a field in which you you list all
the capabilities of humans and then you
cross them off one at a time we achieved
human parrot in X in y&z very dystopian
depressing what happens when you get to
the bottom of the list you know that so
that's very unappealing the other
general thought is that it's true today
and it's going to be true for at least
as far ahead as I can foresee that the
capabilities of machines are very
different and complementary to the
capabilities of people and we know that
when you combine things with different
you know if you combine two classifiers
together with D correlated errors the
performance of the two together exceeds
that of either alone if you look at you
know chess playing machines and they can
beat humans but actually the human and
machine together can beat any human or
any machine ok the center of model I
think that's true very generally so it
give you a very concrete and sort of
very near-term example of a project
which was actually in the in the tech
showcase was is the project called inner
eye so we're there what we're doing is
helping radiation oncologists duration
therapy planning that's a big deal
because half of us have half of all of
us are going to end up with some form of
cancer during our lives than all the
presents that's kind of depressing and
all of those half of those are going to
need radiation therapy so it's a very
big deal but but to have radiation
therapy you fire radiation in from
multiple angles
the idea is to dump as much energy into
the tumor as possible as little energy
into good tissue as possible and
especially a divided loggins so you need
a three dimensional segmentation of the
tumor and a three dimensional
segmentation of sort of vital organs
eyes and whatever else maybe that's
something which is currently done
manually by oncologists looking through
MRI scans slice by slice and segmenting
them it's tedious it's slow the
oncologist gets kind of
and it's not so reproducible it's
screaming out for for using machine
learning that's exactly what that's
exactly what the the inner eye project
does it's not trying to replace the
oncologist is trying to say look here's
the segmentation instead of taking half
an hour an hour three hours in some
cases in a few seconds it gives the
oncologist segmentation they can add
then their expertise and say actually
you know it's not bad but actually I can
refine it and tweak it a little bit
using their experience and in a few
minutes they've got a good segmentation
and it frees up their time to be doing
things they should be doing which is
thinking more qualitatively about the
whole care pathway interacting with the
patient and I don't know how things are
in in the u.s. probably fairly similar
in the UK were facing a shortfall of
around 4,000 radiologists and so we're
really screaming out for technologies
which can empower those radiologists and
make them more efficient and more
effective effectively freeing up the
stuff that that the machines are good at
and leaving people to do the things that
they're good at so I see this
complementarity as intellectually much
more appealing but also actually
something of an imperative shall we just
we're kind of running out of time just
take one more question you get to the
microphone first number two okay
University of Washington so if you look
at what's happened with technology and
business in the last couple of hundred
years every time a major new technology
comes along it leads to to a new kind of
dominant business so you know like in
the second half of 19th century was the
railways and then you know when Ford
invented you know the assembly line that
was a whole new kind of this and you
know I multinationals were the product
of telecoms and air travel and whatnot
and AI surely is one such major new
technology so the question is what is
the business what is the new kind of
business that is going to result from AI
how is it going to be different from
from the businesses that existed and and
how do we get there well I can give it a
try you know at least to share some of
the things that we have been thinking
about Pedro the one one key thing you
know along this line of inouye
in creating all the business until now
until now people do believe that the
magic the magic is in the data so you
have to have data to make interesting
things step that could change you know
in the future but this is where we see
that so people do worry about that is
this does this mean that only the big
five you know the top companies actually
you know have opportunities the rich
gets richer and all this kind of thing
at Microsoft
especially in MSR you know we have been
thinking about this thing you know it
was together with some economists that
we have been thinking about this
particular angle we're actually thinking
about is them what do we call the data
is labor so that might be one very
interesting way to think about the
future as a society and the economy the
business model you know what does this
really even mean you know because if you
think about that you know especially and
I was educated by my colleague Jerry
Lanier you know if this whole ml thing
is going to really dominate you know
would that be doomsday no there's
nothing you know for humans to do you
know that so we don't believe that is
the case you know or you know you really
think that you know there could be that
the humans can continue to contribute
especially the lower part of the society
and the income wise you know what what
can they really contribute to society
and what should be the future future
work you know for those people so I
think that that's one particularly the
direction that we actually think about
it that's that it doesn't really mean
just say you know no we're coming up
with a new company with one particular
business model monopolize everything and
making most of the money is actually
more thinking for the whole society
great thank you very much well we really
are definitely well out of time there so
I know there are more questions but I
think we should probably wrap there so
we can all get off and enjoy a nice
dinner but some you know many many
interesting questions and whatever
happens over the next few years is
clearly going extremely interesting time
for the field of AI I'm gonna invite
sandy back to make a few closing
comments before I do could I just ask
you to join me in thanking Harry for a
fascinating discussion
[Applause]
[Music]